hey guys welcome to the ellen fisher
podcast
[Music]
this idea has been years in the making
and i have been dreaming of this moment
for a long time now
i sometimes neglect to share openly
about important topics online
mostly because i have too many thoughts
to share and not enough room in an
instagram caption to say them
so this podcast will be the perfect
place to not only fully express a topic
but also to have conversations with some
really inspiring and knowledgeable
people
and share their stories and wisdom with
you guys here on the show if you're not
familiar with me or the work i do online
hi i'm ellen i live in hawaii with my
husband andrew and together we are
raising and homeschooling our four
[Music]
children
i've been vegan for 15 years now have
had four wonderfully healthy vegan
pregnancies
and i'm deeply passionate about an
abundant plant-based lifestyle
all four of our children were born in
the comfort of our own home and i love
to help broaden the narrative of birth
to be one of joy and euphoria
my husband and i moved to hawaii eight
years ago when our first child was a
year old to
pursue a life of growing our own food
and living sustainably on our land and
we are finally seeing that dream come
into fruition
i am truly so excited to have you here
i've had a desire and a vision to create
a podcast where i can dig deep in
conversation
and share information that has truly
changed my life more in depth than i
ever have before
on topics that excite me and hopefully
excite you too
which so happens to be more than a few
for me on this podcast you'll find
episodes on
motherhood plant-based nutrition and
ethical veganism
respectful parenting and child nutrition
power of the mind
sustainability financial freedom healthy
pregnancy birth and postpartum and i'm
even gonna dabble in some topics i don't
normally share about including some
other
relevant and important topics in our
time today i love wrestling with
conflicting views and challenging my own
beliefs so that when i come to a
conclusion i know exactly why i feel the
way i do
some of the episodes i'll be talking to
you guys by myself sharing all the
things on a particular subject that
massively has improved my life
and some of the episodes i'll be sitting
down and having conversations with some
really knowledgeable inspiring people
you guys i am
so excited and over the moon about it i
can't even tell you how excited i am
to ask those burning questions and hear
perspectives from such knowledgeable
people these episodes range from
plant-based doctors and nutritionists to
thought leaders around the world to your
favorite inspiring people online to my
sister or best friend down the road with
a moving story to share
every episode will be filled with
valuable and important information so
come to this podcast to restore your
health and relationships
be inspired and empowered in ways that
impact not only you but others and the
world around you
and along the way possibly gain some new
perspectives you have never considered
before
each episode is going to be both
recorded and filmed so you can watch the
episodes here on the ellen fisher
podcast channel
or simply listen on the apple podcast or
spotify app please hit that subscribe
button so you never miss an episode and
i cannot wait to start sharing these
episodes with you
[Music]